hello guys you know the video about the
Godzilla Troy it's not really about the
Godzilla trailer it's about why I didn't
do a video on the Godzilla trailer
initially when it came out but enough a
lot of what you're gonna see in this
video is actually filmed as part of my
Godzilla video but then I realized this
monologue of me talking about this
situation took up half the video just
felt out of place at which point is this
point I'm trying to make eclipsing the
Godzilla trailer video so I just I
essentially took it and split it into
two videos so now you get two videos so
initially when the Godzilla trailer came
out during comic-con I was doing other
comic-con videos and Godzilla trailer
and people were like why didn't you do a
video on that Godzilla trip short answer
is I'm one person I can only do so much
longer answer is not really nostalgic ly
tied to Godzilla I don't know it's just
on a roll of gushing about things I'm
seeing in trailers I'm seeing in
comic-con that are movies that are
happening that I've wanted happen for a
while did a video on glass cuz I wanted
to see an unbreakable sequel since I saw
unbreakable even on Shazam cuz I read
the comic book and I've been interested
in this Shazam movie since it was an
Aquaman because I read Geoff Johns
Aquaman and was interested in a movie
sense and I just don't have that
nostalgia tied to Godzilla I've seen two
Godzilla movies in my entire life the
roland emmerich godzilla movie that kind
of doesn't count and the one that came
out a few years ago and that's it I like
the Godzilla mm trailer and had super
beast by Rob Zombie sweet trailer I mean
Godzilla's cool and all because he's a
big monster who beats up other monsters
and any monster who beats up other
monsters is a cool monster in my book
when comic-con is all about fan
fulfillment right like the coolest
things about the movie trailers at
comic-con is when it's a movie trailer
for something that you're seeing come to
fruition that you've wanted to see for
years right like that's how I am I feel
like that's what you guys do the gotten
I just don't have that with Godzilla
every one of those people there might be
a friend of yours might be an
acquaintance it might be a family member
they really like movies they might even
like the same comic book movies you like
but no throw something like I'm just not
head over heels for Goonies don't get me
wrong I don't hate it I like it just
fine I just don't know all the
characters names I won't get all the
references it's obviously just not part
of my nerd culture DNA but spine movie
though that's kind of me and Godzilla's
suppose it could have faked it
beautifully kitra Mothra and listed off
the things they do what you wouldn't see
is in between the takes I'd be like and
the three-headed dragon hail hydra is
not a hydras oh it's strike light from
mario to the thing from Legend of Zelda
one three-headed
Godzilla dragon monster deidre right
right
I remember that I just like the
motivation for that job hope you
understand I want to talk about the
things that excite me and and if they
excite you too awesome I know people
don't come to my channel wanting me to
posture excitement for the sake of
validating them we've all been there
though I've had trailers and things I've
seen about movies I was really jacked up
for you want to gush about it with a
friend and Friends like I thought it was
okay so you don't really get that
fulfillment I imagine it's much the same
way when it comes to a youtube person
you like to hear talk about movies and
then you have this thing that you really
love and let's say they just don't give
as much of a [ __ ] as you give imagine
that's a bit of a letdown I'm sorry I
mean don't get me wrong like I said in
my Godzilla trailer video that I ended
up doing about the Godzilla trailer that
I uploaded just recently the movie looks
cool and the capacity of that monster is
fighting monsters with human being stuck
in the middle that's cool the visuals
looked really nice but in terms of that
whole oh my gosh I can't even I got
nothin with that I I just feel nothing
and during comic-con I wanted to talk
about trailers that gave me that feeling
I did think pink Rangers pterodactyl
Zord when I saw Rodin on the volcano in
this trailer though I can rap it back to
Power Rangers that's nostalgic for me I
so don't know what I hope to accomplish
in this but just want you to know I just
kind of wanted to keep it real I said
what movie or TV show or video games
does it seem like everyone around you
goes crazy for but not for you you don't
like it almost makes you feel weird but
you know what you're not weird and you
feel it right now you're not supposed to
talk about in the comments section but
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you
[Music]